hey it's Evan and I want you to make
your business more important to you and
I know what you're thinking of course my
business is important to me why am I one
of my you know busting my butt growing
this thing but for all of us there are
days where we're having a hugely
productive day we're out there killing
it another day's wear we're kind of just
floating by you know what I'm talking
about you don't put everything into it
every day you're checking your Facebook
on some days you're answering some
emails you're checking out some news but
you're not really pouring yourself into
it you need to make your business more
important to you you have to imagine
like today is the critical day today is
a defining day for your company the
things you do today will help shape your
entire future you have to make it that
important otherwise you're going to
continue to struggle along and you'll
have some great days but then you'll
fall back and continue being mediocre
and struggling to get by here's a quick
example from my life today I had a radio
show so I'm doing this radio shows my
fifth show today and every show gets
better and I put a ton of pressure on
myself for my radio shows because I want
each one to be way better than the last
because my goal is to help a billion
entrepreneurs that's what inspires me
and that's not going to happen with me
having a mediocre radio show it has to
be great and as entrepreneurs is nobody
pushing us really right if you have a
job if you're not doing a good job your
managers down your throat saying you
need to do better you've got to turn
this thing around or you're fired who's
going to fire you as an entrepreneur
you're your own boss we don't put enough
pressure on ourselves to be great we
work harder for somebody else then we do
for ourselves
you've got to make it more critical so
for my radio show I imagined before my
show in the weekend i'm preparing for it
that i have a big producer have a big
network i have a big potential partner
who's going to be listening to that show
and i have this one show to make an
impression this one show to close an
opportunity and it has to be great if
it's not great I've lost it and it's
never going to happen I put pressure on
myself so that I do the best job
possible and the next time I radio show
comes up I do the same thing I imagined
that this is my one shot and you've got
to do that every day with your business
this is your one shot imagine today this
is your shot today will define if your
business is going to be successful or
not what are you going to do to make
that happen the next customer you talk
to the next media person you talk to the
next supplier working with this is your
defining moment today you've got to
raise the stakes and make it important
it's got to be critical to you and when
you wake up tomorrow again this is your
day tomorrow is your day to I don't want
you to just float by too many
entrepreneurs float by we make enough to
survive to get by maybe to grow a little
bit get some employees for some people
but you're not living the life that you
want to live you're not having the
impact that you want to have and it's
because you're not making that goal
important enough to you it has to be
important do you want that life or are
you okay with what you're doing now
you're okay with being average going
after that life is scary I know it's
painful you're going to have to do
things that are beyond your comfort zone
you're going to have to stretch and
whenever we're confronted with that kind
of potential pain we back off and we
often need people to help us
push through and in a work situation you
have your manager to do that in your own
business you have to be that person and
do whatever it takes to help you realize
the importance of today today is
important for your company what are you
going to do to make it grow that has to
be your mindset every day coming into
the office I found for me that every day
whether was a reset if I had a great day
the next day I'd wake up and I'd have to
motivate myself again everything that
was great that happened yesterday was
like it didn't happen and I have to
start all over and you got to get out of
bed and get motivated what helped me in
the early days was I would read stories
of famous entrepreneurs and I still love
them I look at how guys got started and
how they built up massive empires and
what factors led to their success in
realizing that these guys aren't that
different than me I could do the same
thing they made their business critical
they made it so important that they had
to go and do something today to make
their business take off and they took
that approach every day and they achieve
massive success that motivated me that
got me out of bed that got me going to
work to do something to build my company
now today it's you guys is everybody
watching on my youtube channel and on
facebook and on twitter I wake up I go
get my breakfast i turn on my computer
and I look at the comments that are
getting on my videos and it's great it
makes me feel so good people are saying
how I've changed their lives how they've
started their business and and they're
having an impact now and they thanked me
for what I've done and that makes me
want to do more I realized that if I
don't go out and give it my best today
I'm not going to have an impact and that
motivates me you've got to make today
important why is it so important think
about the life you want to build think
about your ideal dream scenario life
that doesn't happen unless you go out
there
and make what you're doing in your
business important don't flow it around
today don't check facebook don't check
your newsfeed don't chitchat get to work
do something that's going to really grow
your business commit to it and the next
day wake up with that same mentality and
if you need to watch this video over and
over again do it if you don't go to work
today thinking that it's critical today
today is your defining moment today is a
day that everything is going to happen
with your business and if you don't
deliver you're gonna fail that has to be
your mentality if you don't go in with
that mentality you're always going to be
an average entrepreneur and most
entrepreneurs fail and I don't want that
for you and you shouldn't want that for
you so make today important make today
critical do something that you're proud
of today do something that's going to
help somebody I know that it's going to
have a lasting impact in helping you
build the business and the life that you
want for yourself good luck for those
are you watching you know the drill
thumbs up below if you like it and I
want to know you have to think please
leave a comment below I just told you it
motivates me every day so love scene
does come in thank you guys I'll see you
soon